all right welcome to another Friday
Round Table Extravaganza let's get right
into it joining me today is a former New
York City police officer turned Florida
man tered political commentator John
cardillo an author of the new book woke
Army the red green Alliance that is
destroying America's Freedom asra nanii
John asra welcome to the Reuben report
oh thanks so much long overdue yes asra
this is really long overdue I I slid
into your DMs as the kids say about two
weeks ago and I could not believe that
you had not been on the show so uh
John's obviously been on a bunch of
times and my audience is familiar with
him so John you're gonna have to bear
with us for a moment because we're going
to introduce asra to everybody asra why
don't you set up this clip for us
because you you went to the White House
during one of what I call the Hamas
protests not the prop pal Palestine
protest cuz I don't see anyone there
saying anything negative about Hamas but
if you want to clean that up go ahead uh
you were there for that and you you took
a little video is that a good enough
setup that we can throw to it or do you
want to add anything else well you know
I've been walking these streets of
Washington DC for 40 years since I
arrived as a teenager and I know these
streets and on that day the streets of
Washington DC were overrun by this
phenomena that I'm calling the woke Army
and let's let's let it roll and let's
people see what I saw with my very eyes
my back pinned to the iron gates of the
White House only protecting
[Music]
us yo yo about to CL
this
[Music]
all right oser there's an awful lot to
talk about related to this uh as the
evening went on and it got darker it got
kind of scarier out there there was some
vandalism Blood on the gates or you know
paint that was you know supposed to
depict Blood on the gates uh the chants
got louder all of that kind of stuff uh
but you are you are known because you've
been outspoken about this you happen to
be a Muslim woman but um and you've
spoken out against islamism uh must have
been kind of nerve-racked ing for you to
be there in the first place and then can
you just talk about some of the chance
and what you think is really going on as
opposed to the way the mainstream media
frames a lot of this yeah you know
through the afternoon I watched the the
protest and at the protest we saw the
leaders of the woke Army that are the
islamist wing the uh the Muslims that
have established organizations like the
Council on American Islamic relations
American Muslims for Palestine students
for justice in Palestine and what I
heard again and again were political
threats you know and now B Joe Biden had
become genocide Joe so they had created
this narrative now where the Democratic
party had failed them and then I
followed them as they were going down
Pennsylvania Avenue they circled back
around K Street where all the lobbyists
and and lawyers are you know writing the
laws for America they came down 17th
Street and I knew where they were headed
right to the gates of the White House
and sure enough from that footage you
can see that they arrived at the fence
perimeter and they threw the Palestinian
flag between the the spaces of the of
the of the iron fence that they have and
they climbed to top that that gate and
the chants you could hear are the ones
that I have known since I was a child
Allah abbar God is great A simple idea
but now weaponized thck beer that is
what we say when you want to elicit
support for what you're saying and then
this is a sign that everybody has known
right from the river to the Sea
Palestine will be free this is what we
also heard and this is what you hear in
English but what I stood there and I
could hear them saying in Arabic very
loudly is Philistine Al Arabia and the
translation people can hear it is
Palestine is Arab and so the message is
very clear for the genocide of the Jews
from The River To The Sea and what I
could feel Dave in that in those hours
was in this honor shame culture from
which I come there was and there is no
shame for what Hamas has done and
continues to do against the Jewish
people and also the Palestinian people
their Siege of Terror and what there was
was a blood lust that October 7th
Massacre has become a rallying cry and a
moment to seize for the destruction of
the state of Israel and that is why your
work and everybody who elevates the
voices of Jewish people right now is so
critical because the goal is the
destruction of the state of Israel and
people will see this sign it was one of
the signs and it says what workers were
world party this this is the left this
is socialism this is the the Marxist
influence that everybody warns about
it's in the fine print how did I get
these signs cuz I waited like a good
reporter till the end to pick up their
trash and where had they left their
trash on the grass in front of the White
House they put it through those slots
and they trashed the front of the White
House house along with that red paint on
the gates and I am here as a Muslim
American to testify to the danger that
we face today and tell everybody that
whatever you fear is an
underestimation of their
ambition wow John I don't know how
you're going to follow up that kind of
chilling line right there but you know
as a former NYPD guy I guess my question
to you is that as we watch these rallies
and protests and closing of bridges and
closing of public spaces and intentional
targeting of Jewish owned stores and
things of that nature and going to the
Rockefeller Center Christmas tree this
has nothing to do with Jews um what
would you what would New York City have
done in its Heyday as opposed to what it
does now where it lets these people
Rampage through the upper west and
everything else it's one thing I don't
expect the White House to do anything
because I think the White House is
almost in on it at this point but what
do you think new when you were in the
NYPD juliani was in his Hayday how would
this have all been dealt with
differently oh much differently I mean
you know New York City literally wrote
the book on disorder control the New
York City Police Department uh their
disorder control manual Riot nice way of
saying it is the Bible and it's the
Bible not just for United States law
enforcement but for law enforcement
around the world the NYPD Chiefs would
go and train departments uh in the
Middle East and in the Far East but they
would have contained this far better
than we're seeing it contained today and
that's not unique to New York the LAPD
would have done that under Daryl Gates
and then Bill Bratton when they actually
had Chiefs uh you know these guys were
demonized and en villainized for being
racist and oppressive no they were doing
their job right they were chief law
enforcement officers Chicago PD would
have handled these things better because
you got to look at you know we've gotten
to a place and I think oser would agree
Dave you and I have spoken about it
where these Hamas sympathizers are are
linked with black lives matter linked
with antifa they're all operating
together which is why I love the title
of her book and I didn't know about the
book and now I'm looking very forward to
it because uh it's spoton but I'm also
very glad that osar brought up care so
let me give you an anecdote about the
Council on America Islamic relations
they threaten to sue people they talk
about how they're this peaceful uh Civic
organization uh uh for the promotion of
of you know uh honorable uh patriotic
Muslims and let me tell you why that's
an absolute lie here in South Florida in
a little town called myamar Florida in
the southern end of Broward County
there's a mosque I I won't say the name
of the mosque but there's a mosque that
if you go to K's website you can find
that mosque and when you go there it's
not anything impressive it's a little
dinky house so I had found out through
some sources in law enforcement and the
intelligence community that this mosque
uh had some radical ties and that
certain uh people from that Mosk had
done some radical fundraising Etc well
when you look at the when you go to the
Property Appraiser's website for Broward
County and you look at the footprint of
that mosque and and I'm going somewhere
and then it's going to be interesting to
the audience you see facility that's the
mosque and then you see a little white
house on a plot of land owned by the
mosque when I dug into who lives in that
house for life she's got that house for
Life uh if she wants it for free is the
mother of a guy named Adan Al shukri
Juma now he was killed by operators in
Pakistan around 2012 but he was the
architect of the failed New York City
subway bombings so a care sponsored M
and in a pretty uh uh you know obscure
little community in South Florida is is
essentially paying for the livelihood
for the rest of her life of the mother
of one of their terrorist Martyrs these
organizations these organizations are
absolutely about funraising promoting
and enabling Terror and I often tweet
out a simple three-word tweet over
videos uh like osps it simply says
Palestinians equal Hamas equal
Palestinians because like you said in
your opening there is no protest from
any of these Palestinian groups about
the the genocidal Behavior the the
brutal Savage behavior of Hamas on
October 7th because the Palestinians are
nodding and winking these are their foot
soldiers it's not some Fringe group so
law enforcement used to take that stuff
very seriously now they're acting like
people like us are are radical
conspiracy theorists coming up with the
with these asinine Concepts when in
reality we're blowing a very necessary
whistle on a very real problem so aser
it's fairly obvious to me and I think
most people watching this that you guys
are not radical conspiracy theorists
either as a Muslim woman yourself or a
former NYPD guy uh but what would you
say largely in terms of the the American
Muslim Community and of course it's as
vibrant and as any other community and
people have all of their own thoughts
and beliefs and follow their faith
differently differently and everything
else in terms of what what percentage of
people are actually supporting this
stuff because I think that that's the
face we're seeing and if that's not the
face then then I would want to show some
other voices too yeah I mean that's
that's partly why you're here yeah John
what years were you at the NYPD I was
there from the early 90s to the early
2000s so right after 911 okay excellent
so I just want to include your
experience and and what I'm going to
answer da so I arrived in America in
1969 I was a four-year-old girl arrived
at JFK airport and my brother and I were
wearing um striped shirts matching so
that if the flight attendants uh lost us
and they could match us back up together
because my parents had arrived earlier
uh to make a home for us in in at
Ruckers University my dad was the first
person to start Friday prayers at
Ruckers University and he worked with a
man named Mahmud tah from Egypt and in
the 70s they started getting requests to
build a mosque with money from Saudi
Arabia which was now getting its wealth
and so my father and my mother they
practice an interpretation of Islam that
I call an Islam of Grace it is an Islam
that allowed me to be a girl scout it
got me to read Nancy Drew as she was my
best friend as an immigrant girl in
America but what I have here in the
first pages of my book are names that
John is going to recognize it's my cast
of characters Dave to answer your
question these are the people who are
the face of our American Muslim
Community and they are names like number
one is haam basian his name is easy to
remember because if you pronounce it a
different way his nickname is hey um
basian who is he yeah he's the founder
of students for justice in Palestine
that has Unleashed this woke Army onto
our campuses and then a name that maybe
John you might not know John Esposito an
academic at georgtown University who got
first Saudi money and then cutter money
to create the bin talal Center for
Muslim Christian understanding which
monotheistic faith is missing the Jewish
faith then Jonathan Brown omed Safi at
Duke University Council on American
Islamic relations was formed in the
1990s and at their secret meeting the
FBI documented that when they talked
about Hamas they agreed to say Sama I
don't know if you remember that anecdote
John but they were gonna trick yeah I
remember that they were gonna trick the
FBI agents that were they knew were
listening well they messed up and they
would say Hamas once in a while but Dave
the problem problem is we have some 3 to
5 million Muslims in America and yes for
the most part they are not the ones
marching in the streets but the problem
we face is that our leadership is
dominated by anti-American anti-israel I
would argue anti-west and definitely
anti-jew leaders who have their roots in
this organization called Ean Muslim the
Muslim Brotherhood and they are the
Muslim Brothers in America and now they
have their Muslim sisters ilhan Omar
Rashida Talib Linda sarur that are the
face of this radicalization and they do
not represent my family or me but
unfortunately they are the Muslims that
the Biden and Obama administrations have
used as emissaries for us and that is
why I ultimately argue they betray not
only Palestinians and the world but also
Muslims and that's why you know we
formed this Muslim Reform movement a
handful of us some years ago and they
are always constantly trying to crush us
demonize us and make us um the enemy of
Islam but in fact we are I think the
best representation of what Muslims can
be in this not only in America but in
the world asra you've also reminded me
that today is day two of Hanukkah and I
want to wish a very happy Hanukkah to
Rashida Talib and ilhan Omar and AOC and
the rest of them if they only knew the
story of Hanukkah took place and what it
was about it might change some of their
current political views but I sincerely
doubt it all right well actually I want
to jump into a whole bunch of other
topics that I think really are going to
dive right into the reason that your
book is titled such and that red green
Alliance because it's not just about
religion anymore this is about gender
this is about skin color and really it's
what you pointed out to in that in that
sign you were holding that this is how
they are trying to usher in socialism
and communism into America so let's
start with this clip at a congr
Congressional hearing this is AOC one of
the who I call one of the Hamas caucus
members uh trying to explain why we
shouldn't care about biological Boys in
biological girl Sports you I've spent um
decent amount of my time here in
Congress sitting through panels and
hearings of men attempting to restrict
the rights of women and telling us that
it's for our own good um but I want to
dive a little bit more deeply into why
this issue with targeting trans women in
sports is particularly problematic not
just for Trans girls but for all of
us we're here today because there's a
proposal here and there are several
proposals here uh to further
marginalized trans women in sports and I
think about this all the time because
trans people in the United States
doesn't even exceed 1% of our population
and yet there is so many resources and
energy and time dedicated to figuring
out how we can more finely exclude them
um from our Sports and I thought why why
you said there are some proposals I
we've seen this in Ohio there was a
proposed ban on trans athletes that
originally allowed for genital
examinations on minors in
order to quote unquote
protect women is that correct
unfortunately yes yes and so we're
seeing
here in this guise under the guise of
not only trying to further marginalize
trans women and girls we are talking
about opening up all women and girls to
genital examinations when they are
underage that's right potentially just
because someone can point to someone and
say I don't think you're a girl that's
correct all right first off lady they
could just look at the birth certificate
nobody wants to check their genitals
that's number one uh John the way these
people flip language is is just
never-endingly extraordinary when she's
talking about protecting trans women
what she's saying really is oppress
actual girls yep yep look I'm glad you
went there first Dave because as I'm
watching that clip I'm thinking we're
even guilty of playing into their
narrative with terms like trans women
and trans no they're not they're boys
they're boys but you know she defeated
her own argument she admitted as as a
sitting member of the United States
Congress in a Committee hearing room
that the trans population is sub one%
yet we're supposed to just revamp
everything and accommodate sub one% so
so screw the
99.6% of actual women playing these
Sports let's pepper in a bunch of dudes
let's just where are the parents where
are the dads I mean look a a female
student athlete Works their ass off
academically athletically they get a
scholarship they get to a good college
they're about to jump in the pool and Le
a Thomas who can swim along so well
sucked as a male swimmer whatever the
guy's name is jumps in the pool and
destroys destroys everything they spent
a decade and a half working toward to
get there completely wipes out their
chance for records their name on the
wall and that school maybe in the
athletic hall of fame maybe making it to
the Olympic team because they play it is
so Preposterous but it's also tragic it
is incredibly tragic that we are
subjecting little girls to this and now
there's a story I forget where it came
out of it was pretty big news last
couple of days how a a a young girl was
forced to sleep with a boy who felt he
was trans and the parents notified about
it retroactively to me this is Criminal
people need to start going to prison for
this well actually in our free State of
Florida it is Criminal um which gives us
a nice segue let me let me throw to an
interview that Nikki Haley did that this
got her in a bit of hot water uh because
she was saying that basically if a
12-year-old wants to transition that we
should kind of leave it up to them and
the parents and there's some interesting
stuff here related to limited government
and parental rights that I think you can
have a nice debate on let's take a look
Madame Ambassador another question is
what care should be on the table when a
12-year-old child in this country
assigned female at Birth says I feel
more comfortable living as a boy what
should the law allow the response to
be I think the law should stay out of it
and I think parents should handle
it parents should handle it now I think
there's probably a way you can make
principled arguments on this and it
depends what you think about limited
government and everything but in that
this has become so disregulated if it is
not for the government to defend the
right of that kid to keep their body
parts until they are of age then I don't
know what the purpose of the government
government is AER is that is that a bit
much for you no not at all because you
know we have a constitutional right in
the United States of America as parents
that's what's remarkable we have free
speech rights and we have parental
rights and what is happening now is just
like John was saying like and just as
you were saying there is a machine there
is an industry that is rewriting our
language and rewriting our laws to
remove those kind of rights that we have
I I just teared up in my own self my my
younger self listening to AOC because I
brought knowing that we were going to
talk about this and a symbol of my
empowerment as a girl in America this is
a baton it's a relay race baton right
and when I was 10 years old in
Morgantown West Virginia where we moved
a girl named Jane Thomas called me the
new immigrant Girl in Town and said hey
will you join our relay team and all of
a sudden I got to run with Linda
mccrosky and Lisa mccrosky and Jane
Thomas they were the uh popular girls I
was never going to reach that Social
Circle why am I a strong woman here
before you today with my voice coming
from a culture where I was told silence
is golden which my adversaries would
wish I had followed for the rest of my
life why am I here because Sports
empowered me in West Virginia I ran
track I ran cross country and became a
strong young woman then but now this is
industry this book
gaybcs is just one of the many books you
know that has been spotlighted by us as
parents tea is no longer for train but
it's for Trans so that 1% that AOC
talked about we're write rewriting books
to so that that 1% can grow which hey if
it grows it grows but we don't need to
steal constitutional rights in order to
allow people to live in the United
United States with freedom and
empowerment and and ultimately also
uplift our girls John is there a little
bit of a catch 22 with this one and that
I obviously agree with asra and we are
the parental rights people uh but by
Nikki saying the government shouldn't
defend that 12-year-old in a time when
the culture is pushing it on everybody
to encourage transitioning maybe this is
one of the moments and this has been
desantis's position which is that this
is one of the moments where the
government actually does have to step in
and defend those kids yeah look I agree
man and I'm a small government guy you
and I have had this conversation offline
countless times right but uh about
various issues Second Amendment and Etc
but uh case look all somebody has to do
is watch that show I am Jazz that
lunatic mom and the cuck old dad to see
that some of these parents should not be
making these calls I mean you've got a
depressed kid whose borderline suicidal
nobody wants to call it out and say it
for what it is who's now almost morbidly
obese because the mom thought it was
cool to be a radical leftist with a
trans kid I belong to a beach club here
and and a family they actually kicked
out for being weird OD deviant pretty
much forced their kid their their little
uh girl to dress like a boy and the kid
was miserable and the kid wanted to be a
little girl and they would these radical
leftist well-known leftist a pretty
affluent family and everybody at the
club was was sick of it and and one of
the women there would would babysit the
kid and told me that what she saw in the
house sickened her the way they were
forcing this kid the parents into this
trans lifestyle when the kid just wanted
to be a normal kid of the gender they
were born so as much as it pains me to
Advocate government intervention I on
this issue if if you were to do an
honest study I think you would find that
many of these kids if not the vast
majority if not all of them are being
pushed by these parents who think it's
cool I mean imagine oh we know this
there there are a lot of studies that
that show that mutilating your child
because you want to be accepted by a
bunch of other knuckles had leftist at a
dinner party is there anything worse I I
I mean if you're not going to protect
your own kid from that then the
government does have to step in so I
want to connect this to something else
because obviously we're talking about
support for a genocidal terrorist
organization we're talking about
mutilation of children and then the
other thing that is now happening is it
seems to me that we are now letting
anyone and everyone gladly walk into
this country and if you say anything
about it they will call you of course a
racist or a Nazi take a look at a little
bit of a compilation of videos that are
just from the last week what's going on
at our
border
I love you Joe Biden thank you for
everything Joe Biden I'm good person I
want to be good person here in the
United States I came here because I want
quality life you know America is a lot
is a land of opportunity
asra what happened to what it says on
the Statue of Liberty something about
you're poor you're tired your huddled
masses these people all look relatively
young they look relatively healthy and
wellfed most of them the large
percentage of them are male uh we don't
do any vetting on any of these people
it's very nice that he thinks America's
pretty great he actually thinks
America's better than most progressives
seem to think it is uh but you you can't
not have a border no you have to have a
border and having traveled many borders
I know how hard it is to cross them you
know I have tried to cross between India
and Pakistan not easy into Afghan I bet
you that one's not easy it was not easy
do you know what I mean I was at the
corner of India at the China border I
wasn't going to be able to take a step
into China you know it just doesn't
happen anywhere else in the world like
we have allowed such a poorest system
and as an immigrant I can testify to
everything that we just heard heard
about the beauty of America the world
over wants to come here except for the
progressives that want to exactly taint
our beautiful Nation but we must be a
nation of laws and ultimately what what
is the connective tissue in all of this
there is an ideology happening sweeping
through this nation in which it is
transforming the identities of children
allowing the identity of what it means
to be an American to be hijacked and
ultimately Waging War with those that
should be our friends such as the Jews
and Israel and so it is a hijacking of
America from every front from our inner
selves to our external relations with
our allies and then our borders and the
truth of the matter is that there is a
political motivation right there's a
motivation to try to change demographics
and congressional districts and we have
to be really clear about that you know
this isn't some altruistic effort that's
happening there's multi-million dollar
uh organizations that are leading these
Caravans allowing the registration then
to voting taking away identity rules
when it comes to voting there's a a a a
trajectory that is meant to ultimately
inform seats in Congress and uh who the
identity of our politician will be in
the White House and so let's not be um
you know naive I think and and we
certainly aren't here at the round table
but let us not allow this nation to be
hijacked as it is today so John I I
think you're probably on board the
sentiment there about a nation being
hijacked but again I want to just bring
it to the law enforcement part for you
because that's your specialty uh so it's
sort of a same question that I asked you
about the NYPD but when you see the
Border guards there and they're just
letting them through and sometimes
they're literally opening up the door
there's like there's a door on some of
these fences they open up a door they
let 12 people through then they say wait
a second they tell them go that way to
Chicago go that way to San Diego I mean
I'm literally not making this stuff up
what is going on with that chain of
command and and do you have sympathy for
the guys that are there I kind of
sympathize with them I don't know how
they can do their job when they're being
basically told not to yeah look a very
good friend of mine was uh a border
patrol Intel uh he's now with Homeland
Security he's an agent there but um it
he was back there about 15 20 years ago
and the situation was bad then you know
and uh but not like it is today the Rank
and file not like the FBI the FBI Rank
and file now is very woke and and they
are in lock step with guys like Chris
Ray so when guys like Sean Hannity go
the rank and file it's nonsense I it's
getting worse in the bureau but the
border control these guys want to do
their job let me just say one thing
about that video so we watch that video
As Americans as conservatives we get
enraged right at 30,000 foot level we
see all these people pouring across a
fence something not much scares me that
I watch something in that video scared
me I looked at about I watched just now
about 20
Chinese fighting aged males and more
than a few of them but a dozen of them
were very comfortable standing at
military parade rest while waiting be
processed or turned around that should
be concerning if that's their default
stance that should be concerning that
that many Chinese fighting age males
came through a fence came through a hole
in a fence the border patrol Rank and
file these guys want to turn them back
they want to put him right back through
the fence mayorcas should be impeached I
mean I think I think the GOP the house
is is missing a very easy political win
where they won't have to burn much
political Capital you impeach my orcus
Democrats then have to defend that video
Play that video during his impeachment
proceeding and make Democrats defend
what we just watched bring in a guy like
Mike Waltz a congressman here in Florida
who's was he's the first Green Beret
elected to congress let him analyze
those Chinese fighting age males those
Arab Muslim fighting age males and give
his assessment as a Green Beret
Commander a special forces commander on
what he thinks the end result of that
will be because I can tell you I know
Mike a guy like Mike is going to tell
you the disaster we're letting into our
country so when I look at that I want to
see my orcus impeached and in prison I
want to see the same for Joe Biden over
this but I'm worried very worried about
lowtech asymmetrical attacks in this
nation coming from these people I'm
absolutely worried about that and that
is not Hyperbole and that is not you
know scare for media you know if it
bleeds it leads this is a genuine
concern of mine no I'm completely with
you and and I also think that at some
point especially if we get another four
years of a Democrat Administration the
states are going to have to just start
dealing with their own borders as they
see fit and you know fortunately for us
John we're here in Florida where we got
three water borders and we've got a
coast guard we're going to have to deal
with Georgia and Louisiana but okay I I
want to connect this though to something
that's going on across Europe right now
because obviously we've seen these Hamas
rallies and this Pro Palestine stuff
we've seen it in Brussels and we've seen
it in France and London and elsewhere uh
but but Ireland has a really bizarre
situation going where they're they're
extremely Pro Palestine it's it's osra
maybe you can explain a little bit of
what's going on on that but but not only
that they've also had a bunch of
stabbings and other violent attacks by
illegal immigrants it's led to riots and
a whole bunch more uh but they do have
occasionally a senator that wisen up to
some of this this is Irish Senator
Sharon kogan and listen to her make the
connection between illegal immigration
having no borders and the obvious
results of that firstly onti
H statement yesterday that it is not
right to connect immigration with crime
is ridiculous not all immigrants are
created equal and an immigration policy
that does not recognize this will end in
disaster and tragedy we don't record
crime statistics by ethnicity because to
do so would offend liberal sensibilities
but other European countries do the
Dutch do they've done it for 10 years
and here's what they've found
individuals from non-western immigration
background make 14% of the population in
the Netherlands however they commit 40%
of all crime and violent assaults
populations from Africa or the Middle
East tend to exhibit rates of two to
four times higher than those of native
Dutch and in both Germany and Spain the
suspect rate of Algerian immigrants for
crimes is 10 times that of Natives and
in Italy it is 17 times and Ireland has
the largest groups of Algerian Asylum
seekers in the world been admitted into
the country asking us not to asking us
not to commit connect crime to
immigration is asking us to ignore
reality well now Ireland has the eyes of
the world on it and they're posed to see
how this country is being turned into a
post Democratic EU vassel state which is
about to pass censorship legislation the
likes of which we' have never seen in
the west so that its government will be
protected from the criticism of the
people it is elected to
government maybe maybe that will pause
give them pause for thought but I won't
hold my
breath okay this Brave woman is
obviously telling the truth and I think
in most Western European capitals if
they could reverse everything they did
for the last 10 years they would Angela
Merkel has even admitted in Germany and
yet asra it's exactly what we're doing
right now in America letting all of
these people in and not all cultures are
equal are they yeah you know and I told
you guys the story of arriv in this
country in the 1960s and the Muslim
Brothers arriving as my father did well
my father refused that Saudi money right
in building a mosque in the United
States but what the fundamental problem
is that the immigrants that are coming
in from Muslim countries that want to
replicate the most totalitarian systems
that they knew of religious
interpretation or want to then also put
on the United States or the west and
Europe
are the ones that are gaining so much
power this woke Army that I write about
is not just in the United States it's in
Europe it is the far-left in Europe that
has aligned with the islamists that have
created these quote Pro Palestinian
rallies but they are not pro Palestinian
just like you said they are at a minimum
anti-israel and anti-jew and then I
agree with you completely they are pro
Hamas and who are they John knows these
people and these institutions very well
their organizations like hisb terer they
have a base in Northern Virginia I went
to their meeting at a Red Roof you know
not many years ago they are in our
Western capitals and I know this all
very personally because in 2002 I was
renting a home in Karachi Pakistan my
colleague from The Wall Street Journal
was the journalist Daniel Pearl mhm
Danny came to my house for an interview
with his wife maryan just pregnant and
he left for That interview and he never
came back the man who orchestrated his
kidnapping leading him then to the
murder and the beheading of Dany in a
sign of things to come
today was a man named Omar shake
radicalized at the London School of
economics in London through the briti
British Muslim Community and that was in
the 1990s that he was radicalized so
this has been decades in the making and
the answer that the west and the United
States has to make is that people have
to uphold the values and principles that
we believe in this nation so you cannot
advocate for example for the
extermination of an entire nation and
the genocide of the people that live
there and the those guard rails have to
be put up so that they cannot exploit
our freedoms to then destroy our
freedoms John you know I don't like
doing the black pill on this show but to
some extent when you hear asra say that
um and then we look at those videos of
the people coming in isn't it kind of
like well the ship has sailed they're
here we don't have the political will to
do much of anything anymore and we don't
have competent leaders uh in some ways
on either party we've got one guy here
in Florida but beyond that we just don't
so it's like how could this get better
yeah right and we don't have the bodies
to do it look the os's point about this
being decades in the making she's she's
a th% correct I've got a good friend
who's a federal agent recently retired
federal agent and he was detailed to the
US Embassy in Paris 20 years ago as that
agency's at pese to work with you know
the heroin uh trafficking and all that
he was DEA and they tell you there
aren't uh Muslim no-go zones in Paris
they lie they lie they were there 20
years ago when he and the Agents had to
go to certain areas and and they uh
would go with with the Parisian police
there were times those areas so rough
the Marine security guard detail would
go with them and those no-o zones have
been there so osar is 100% right they've
been there for decades but let's black
pill this to a degree that I that I hate
to there are about 20 some odd million
if we're being conservative legals in
the nation right you've only got about
700,000 State local and federal law
enforcement officers and I mean from the
the FBI on down to the smallest Town
Police Department they would have to do
nothing all day every day 247 365 never
take vacation never take a day to make a
minuscule dent in terms of apprehensions
and deportations we simply don't have
the manpower to go out and Deport all of
these people so you have to stop them
before they come in because right now
it's a cleanup effort right like right
now it's sanitation it's it's not
proactive uh uh policing proactive law
enforcement the more they let in
eventually that that sewer overflows and
there's nowhere for the sewage to go and
we're getting to that point if we're not
already at that point so no you're
you're not blackpilling unfortunately
you're just being pragmatic you're being
a realist well speaking of sewage I want
to get to the Congressional hearing from
earlier in this week that caught fire
online and anytime you talk about MIT
Harvard and upen sewage is involved uh
they had the three presidents of course
of those universities up there to uh
talk about their bullying and harassment
policies as it pertains to Jews because
these schools have become obviously hot
beds of Hamas Insanity uh take a look at
video One Alise stefanic who's a
Democrat from new sorry she's a
republican from New York don't want to
get that one wrong she's a republican
from New York she was doing most of the
questioning Dr Korn Bluth yes does m at
MIT does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate mit's code of conduct or
rules regarding bullying and harassment
yes or no if targeted at individuals not
making public
statements yes or no calling for the
genocide of Jews does not constitute
bullying and harassment I have not heard
calling for the genocide for Jews on our
campus but you've heard chance for
inapa I've heard chance which can be
anti-semitic depending on the context
when calling for the elimination of the
Jewish people so those would not be
according to the mit's code of conduct
or
rules that would be um investigated of
as harassment if pervasive and severe
Miss Migel at Penn does calling for the
genocide of Jews violate depends rules
or code of conduct yes or
no if the speech turns into conduct it
can be harassment yes I am asking
specifically calling for the genocide of
Jews does that constitute bullying or
harassment if it is directed and severe
or pervasive it is harassment so the
answer is yes it is a context dependent
decision congresswoman it's a context
dependent decision that's your testimony
today calling for the genocide of Jews
is depending upon the context that is
not bullying or harassment this is the
easiest question to answer yes Miss
Migel so is your testimony that you will
not answer yes if it uh is if the speech
becomes if the speech becomes conduct it
can be harassment yes conduct meaning
committing the act of
genocide the speech is not harassment
this is unacceptable Miss Migel I'm
going to give you one more opportunity
for the world to see your answer does
calling for the genocide of Jews violate
Penn's code of conduct when it comes to
bullying and harassment yes or
no it can be harassment the answer is
yes asra I have no doubt you've seen
that several times everyone watching
this has seen it several times it gets
worse every time I mean the duplicity
this idea that somehow the language has
to turn into action so okay so then when
the kids are dead then I guess maybe
it's mild bullying but I want to connect
it to something that you started with at
the top of the show uh the duplicitous
use of language and in that context you
were talking about it when they use some
of these phrases in Arabic but we're
seeing them do it in English right in
front of our faces under oath at the the
same time yeah and I want I have watched
that yes hundred times because each time
I hear those words I see the threat we
face and it's the threat from within
what has happened is that the presidents
of our ivy league institutions have
become Hostage to the woke Army and the
money that is Flowing from governments
like qar and Saudi Arabia and turkey
into our universities creating Beach
heads on these
institutions I know it personally
because I taught journalism at
Georgetown University and then I went
into the Crosshair of Georgetown
University's B tal Center where they
have the so-called Bridge initiative and
was dismissed and demeaned and and uh
and smeared as a islamophobe because I
dared to stand up against Islamic
extremism followed the money and it is
Flowing from foreign bank accounts into
our University campuses they created you
know campuses NYU has created them in
the Middle East and cutter all these
places so when you hear the those um
that Heming and haul from those three
academics it's because they are now
speaking the language of the woke Army
in hijacking free speech in the United
States in order to deny people their
right to live with safety and and and
even live just live because what has
been argued is a genocide of the Jews
and that has been the chant of the
students for Justice in Palestine Camp
uh chapters and what is the solution it
has to be barred these organizations
have to be barred from our campuses the
academics that promote th that hate
speech have to be disallowed as as uh
teachers in our campus culture and that
those institutions have to stop
accepting money from these foreign
governments John do you view this sort
of as the end of liberalism that that's
kind of where I'm at at this that we now
have people in the system in the country
who as Asar is pointing out are using
all of our freedoms against us they are
playing duplicitous Lang games with
language and yes if you you can you can
make the argument I suppose that from
The River To The Sea isn't saying kill
all those people I suppose there's an
that's not what I agree with but there's
a I see how you can use language in a
duplicitous way to make that point but
at some point the the Liberals cannot
defend themselves anymore and we're
going to have to start relooking at some
of our documents I'm not I'm not talking
about stop changing anything related to
free speech but being a more mature
society when the bar barbarians are at
the gate literally right I mean look the
one the one good thing about Sally corn
Bluth and Mill and all those lunatics is
you didn't even have to play the Audio I
could have just looked at their faces
they all have that look Randy weart has
that look that like just they look dirty
and unkempt and miserable and they they
at least they identifi themselves
without speaking right but how
Preposterous you know think about ilhan
Omar right there was always a popular
narrative that ilhan Omar won her won
her seat uh in that Minneapolis area
because of Somali Muslims but that's not
how she won her seat the entire voter
Universe of Somali Muslims in that area
with 30,000 she won her first race by
243,000 votes it was white liberal
academics that putan Omar into the
United States Congress and and we know
who they are but what I think we need to
start doing our things like the santis
does you know if if you're a a Harvard
endowment and you want to start uh uh
going uh playing ball with all these
radical lunatic murderers uh uh
genocidal lunatics not a penny of your
money should be able to be invested a
penny of the state's money Florida's
money in endowment not a penny of
pension fund money the only way you're
going to hurt these institutions is if
you start hitting them in the wallet and
I don't mean you know the jabbing them I
mean knocking them in the head with
sledgehammers pulling bill billions upon
billions upon billions out the big Banks
won't do it they're the absolute worst
because they're beholden to the Saudis
and the qataris and and half of the
Emirates but uh if they started if they
started pulling out and if they started
reversing all it would take is one CEO
with guts to start reversing this trend
sadly they don't seem to exist but yes I
think it's the end of
liberalism classic liberalism uh I think
it's been dead for a while because what
we're seeing right now the irony right
of of of green haired radical lunatics
in Pride Flags uh going to bat for the
irgc you know they're re revolutionary
guard Corps and saying we're the bad
guys in America for daring to kill
solomani I mean it's just all hope is
lost with those people and I think
unfortunately what we just saw those
those women are are Academia I'm not
going to say you know that they're
pervers they are Academia and gay gays
for Palestine is a little different than
Palestine for gays yeah asra can you I
want to give you the the final word here
what do you think in terms of you gave
us a very Stark warning a moment ago
John gave us a stark warning just before
that how do we defend the freedoms of
America and freedom of speech and all of
the beautiful traditions we have when we
know the enemy is inside using
everything against us we don't have
great political leaders uh our our our
institutions have seemingly failed us
what is the actual white pill if we've
done a little black pilling today yeah
you know to me there's this concept that
my son actually told to me I was weeping
one day because I was the target of this
assault by my own Muslim Community
calling me all sorts of names including
Jew Zionist media because of this
hate for for is their hate for Israel my
son I don't know that disappearance is
going to help you very much yes I know
I'm lean into it I lean into it and
where but we have great dinners down in
Florida you're welcome many time I'm I'm
arriving well my son put his hand his
hand on my shoulder and he said Mom stop
crying because they are terrorists of
the mind and the greatest betrayal we
can give the freedoms that we enjoy is
when we allow our minds to become
hijacked by the propaganda and by the
ideological uh you know um uh guilt that
they try to put on us I am sitting
before you as a classic liberal one
still survives and I will fight for
classic liberalism just like I will for
Islam because that is what we must do we
we we've spoken about the noble efforts
of law enforcement but how they are
limited the noble efforts of those
trying to protect our legal legal system
also so we as citizens must rise up with
moral courage defy the fear that is
going to be in each one of our hearts
because we believe in the humanity that
is our lives you know that is what we
have enjoyed what we appreciate what we
want to see for our children our
grandchildren and so we are the answer
we can create the nation that we want to
see in the world and and it does rest on
us we cannot wait for the Cavalry from
any front because we are the Cavalry
yeah ashra first time appearance and a
brilliant ending to the show you are
definitely welcome back John will have
to discuss this over tequila whether you
can come back we and as a Muslim
reformer as a Muslim reformer I'm going
to join you in that tequila sh one day
anytime anytime uh have a great weekend
guys oh and one more time just happy
Hanukkah to Rashida to leave all right
see you
everybody